Denmark has started to ease some of
those restrictions what are you doing
well we lifted some of the restrictions
last week the students in primary
schools in kindergartens and nurseries
are now back and tomorrow on Monday
we're going to lift some other
restrictions so for example dentists are
going back to work
beauty clinics are going back the
hairdresser's are going back small
businesses are opening up and why did
you decide to ease these things before
others what what is it specifically
about those early restrictions that
you've lifted
well well first of all all our key
indicators are pointing in the right
direction if we look at the number of
people in hospital the number of people
in intensive care the people number of
patients on ventilators these numbers
have been staple or have been coming
down the last two weeks or so so we are
definitely not out of the woods yet but
we are moving in the right direction and
we can't stay in a lockdown forever so
this decision about the schools and the
primary schools and the kindergartens is
based on scientific advice to the
government as such several models have
been presented to the government and
this was the one which was chosen it
might sound strange but the the children
in this contact it's not a vulnerable
group and that's probably one of the
reason why they chose to open the
schools it's also vital for our economy
if you want people to go back to work
work we have to make it possible for the
students to go back to the schools and
the small kids to go to the nurseries
and to the kindergartens of course as
soon as you start to ease some
restrictions we don't know what will
happen to the virus it's very much a
tentative process if those numbers start
to rise again of infections could we see
the lock down tightly again and in
Denmark the Prime Minister has made it
very clear that will following follow it
day by day
and I mean if the numbers are pointing
in the wrong directions we'll have to
impose restrictions again so we're also
telling the Danes that we are lifting
some of the restrictions but they still
have to behave like they have been doing
for the last month they should keep a
social distance there shouldn't be
gatherings of more than ten people
peoples who still work from home we
still close our borders etc so we're not
lifting all the restrictions we're
eating some of the restrictions and then
we'll closely follow the development
during the coming days and weeks and do
you think it helps that you are
effectively giving the people in Denmark
two messengers here you're saying look
things are getting better so we can
start to leave some of the restrictions
but you have to behave responsibly
you're trusting people it does work
before Easter the Prime Minister told
the Danes that it would be possible to
lift to ease some of the restriction if
they behaved during Easter time during
these wonderful summer temperatures if
they behaved responsibly if they
continued what they had done the first
30 weeks then we would be able to open
up again so I mean it was sort of a pact
between the government and the
population now Denmark moved very
quickly in the early stages of the virus
you were one of the first countries to
go into quarantine do you think that is
part of the reason why you're now able
to lift some of those measures now well
I'm not an expert but I think it's it's
the restrictions have worked so far the
Danes have respected their restrictions
and now finally there seems to be light
at the end of the tunnel but I also have
to emphasize we're not out of the woods
yet one of the key things that people
are talking about when it comes to
moving forward getting out of the
lockdown it's testing what's Denmark's
attitude been to testing and how
important is testing in the fight
against Kovac 19 testing is very
important we are testing about 5,000
people at Dien a day but we are also
going to change our strategy because
right now we are testing people with
sentence but we're going to test a large
proportion of the population in in the
futures and the days to come and right
now we are building more testing
facilities in the parks of the major
cities in in Denmark we don't have the
details of the new strategy yet it's a
it's a political decision that we're
going to elaborate a strategy during the
coming days and then we'll open up for
more testing and just finally the
president of the EU Commission
apologized to Italy this week for not
doing more to help that country at the
start of the corona virus outbreak in in
big crisis is like these many countries
will turn to the EU for help do you
think they should have done more you can
always do more and I'll maybe and it's
also easy to to see afterwards what you
should have done this is an
unprecedented situation and and I mean
the handing of the crisis was something
that you had to do on the spot I think
the most important thing for any
government is to look at your own
citizens first but also of course to
look at the International Corporation as
sorts and we have also tried to assist
Italy we have sent ventilators to Italy
we have also sent mobile and Hospital
such small of course because I've done a
lot more but also it's it's hard it's
very important to emphasize that health
issues as such is not the competence of
the European Union or of the
Commissioner sorts it's the national
competence there's a lot of coordination
going on in the European time for the
time being there's a lot of financial
assistance going to the affected
countries Italy felt abandoned they
didn't they they felt that at a time of
crisis other EU countries look to their
own nations first yes they do and I
don't blame them I mean but also as I
said before when you're hit by an crisis
you have never experienced before the
worst crisis worst health crisis we have
ever seen the worst crisis we have
encountered since the Second World War
of course any government is first and
foremost looking at its own citizens and
then at the latest states try to open up
for more international
corporation